I'm so tired of these movies with these
women in charge where every single movie
now all these shows are just it's a
recreation of something that was in the
80s they just recreate recreate recreate
because no one's having any real ideas
anymore like where does that come from
like why I think that there's a bigger
agenda play it like if you believing in
God and having a higher power in your
life like believing in something bigger
than you makes you more powerful and
makes you more happy but if you have the
masses plugged into like celebrity
worship if they're watching garbage
content if there's no art if
everything's soulless if everybody's
always polarized and arguing everyone's
yelling at each other and if we're like
watching Satan on on TV then we are
going to be Dumber we're going to be
easily controlled they're doing well
right now they're winning the culture
war on the right everybody wants to be
the idol wants to be the person with all
the influences so we end up fighting
each other and going back and forth
about who we should look up to yeah but
the problem with the right is some of
them it's like undercover feminism for a
lot of them that they don't know it if
you have to
go out of your way to be a man and
everyone everything is telling you that
it's the wrong thing to do then why not
just put on some makeup and give up and
even like being in in sports you know
that's like a typically like male
dominated like you know men are better
at sports right really
good thing you got out of volleyball now
you'd be destroyed by Dylan
what up guys welcome to the just curly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down part two
um welcome to Nico back to the channel
um London you had what two million
YouTube subscribers I think I right now
if I had it I would have around six
million if I was still on I think it
would be six million and
it's too bad and your views were just
crazy at the time yeah it skyrocketed a
lot it was within I had one million and
then I started streaming and then my
second channel was just about a million
and then I got terminated and and what I
respect about you is you were on YouTube
for literally what 10 15 years 10 years
10. well I had other channels when I was
younger but it was 10 years on that same
sneako channel
and yeah it's it's too bad I've been
reposting some of the videos on Twitter
you guys can follow me there at sneako
on Twitter and be reposting some of my
favorite videos my artistic videos it's
fun seeing your studio here and how you
have all these systems set up and how
you're creating more content is bringing
new editors and more people here I'm in
a phase where I'm trying to shift away
from that a little bit I like being
guests on other people's shows but I
think it's time to bring real art back
and that's what a lot of that's like one
of my core fans that's what they really
love my videos for was that artistic
stuff that separated me from other
YouTubers and then I got really into the
streaming which I love streaming but I
started doing I made this video um 2019
called quality over quantity and in that
video I talked about how I would never
want to make eight reaction videos a day
and how that's spamming it but then I
said I started doing that yeah I would
stream and then just react to videos and
upload it but it was just making so much
money and there was so much growth after
being what I I thought that I was put in
this box where it was like every
YouTuber's favorite YouTuber and then
part of the reason why I started live
stream was seeing people react to my
videos that I spent a lot of time on and
they will get more viewers and they
would make more money reacting to it on
I spent a month making something and
they could just like this is like an
incel in five minutes that they can just
uh it just it polarizes you it forces
you into a box so I was like I could do
that better than them yeah and you're
I loved your interviews that's actually
where I first found you was your street
interviews that you used to do with your
commentary on the side
um
I don't know I think what's really
unique about you is you really do
everything like you you can react you
can do interviews you can do the
artistic pieces yeah I like I just love
making content but I I want to transcend
out I've been banned so instead of so it
was it was interesting seeing you
approach to show me around the whole
studio and you want to create more
systems and create more shows and I'm I
was thinking in my head like I don't
ready to to move on to the next thing
I'm ready to transcend and try to make
some higher for there's not a lot of art
anymore when's the last time you watched
a movie
I don't remember was last time you
watched the show I just I don't remember
I don't remember either I I just watched
like podcast Clips I just watched stuff
like I'm on Twitter but there's no good
and even the movies that people talk
about they talk about the Mario movie
all everything half the movies are
welcome now it's just Peach it's
Princess Peach and she's a girl boss I
didn't watch it but like I see her she's
running around oh my God I'm so tired of
these I'm sorry they're not that many
women bosses I'm so tired of these
movies with these women in charge where
which was getting saved in a castle by
Bowser for 30 years and then she gets in
a Mario movie and now she's there like
in charge jumping over Cliffs and
stopping our Goombas like every single
movie now all these shows are just it's
a recreation of something that was in
the 80s they just recreate recreate
recreate because no one's having any
real idea real ideas anymore I think
it's the fall of social media the
everyone having to follow this specific
agenda people not wanting to take risks
or get called
so there's a real demand for for art
right now so I want to take that
um I want to take that position I didn't
know about that that's so
so it sucks yeah it's not like original
content nothing everything is like is a
recreation of something from the 80s
like I can't even think of the last
fresh movie to come out
the culturally impactful movies that
came out like a joker and that's a
spin-off of Batman which we see a new
Batman movie every year Joker was like
the most culturally impactful movie but
to my head nothing
what won the Oscar I don't know
remember when that mattered no nobody
even believes in the award shows anymore
no one cares about the Grammys
you can steal 950 worth of items from a
Walgreens in New York and they can't
call the police
like you can just stay I was that's why
I left New York I was just waiting in
line like a bot and everyone's like just
okay here's my cough syrup and then
someone I thought that he was working at
the Walgreens he has all these crates
and he's just putting all the beer into
the crates and like oh he works there
like oh good employee and then he takes
it and it's like where is he pushing
this and he just walks out the door and
Security's staying there okay and I'm
like holding my stuff like I'm such a
bot I I I'm like should I steal too yeah
but I didn't but and I asked the cashier
like why don't you do anything it's like
it's under 950 we can't call the police
why so you can just steal
and you're not a criminal
it's there's no way that this is going
to end up well or we just tolerate it
and we allow this to happen but you see
that and you're like why am I here you
were asking me about Japan Japan is a
place where you don't even litter you
don't even want to play music on the
train you don't want to like disrupt
other people you don't like I noticed my
like my pants were sagging a little bit
by accident I'd pull them up because
like I didn't want to upset the grandma
near here I have tattoos on my arms and
I would cover them because I don't want
to that even tattoos is degenerate in
Japan you don't want to contribute to
any of that you want to contribute to
the peace and to how everybody is that
everybody's respectful everybody
wants you to enjoy life as well there's
not there's no polarization in Japan
there's none of that like people look at
each other weird mean mugging each other
after seeing what's possible outside
I don't understand like why you would
invest more time into being in these
places it's hard I just miss my family
and my family's in Chicago
um I don't know it's possible I can move
somewhere else but it's like what I
would go to what Dubai or something and
now I'm up 20 hours from my family right
yeah how do you like where do you where
do you go when it's like you're starting
over in a brand new place knowing nobody
and it's hard because I have nine
siblings and I'm just close with them
I'll make a lot of money move them all
out get them all out of there oh gosh
maybe I'll try do you want to hear my so
you're getting in trouble for the repeal
19. you want to hear my your most
controversial my new controversial take
okay
okay Dubai works because there is Arab
Supremacy
like I grew up with um like nannies from
around the world and like Americans have
this
lack of respect for other cultures where
they don't feel like they need to
immigrate like into the culture or sorry
assembly yeah into the culture so if
they go somewhere they feel like the
culture should appease them when it's
like no you're like when I went to I
can't remember where it was Hydra bad
maybe or some I just remember somewhere
I had to wear the to go in the temple
like people would say that's
misogynistic or sexist or whatever but
it's like it's disrespectful you're
going you're going to their culture so
respect it yeah everybody in America
when you these westernized societies
everyone's like they're not proud of the
place people aren't proud of being
American there's no only people who are
proud to be an American or Maga people
are the Trump supporters like they love
the country that's why I like Trump
because he loves America I'm like I'm
come from an immigrant family too but I
respect that he loves his country most
of the people all the people in the West
in New York and Chicago La they hate
America genuinely they think that waving
the American flag is like these are the
colonizers this is racist and it's a
symbol of slavery they it's almost
become the new Confederate flag the
American flag everybody always latches
on so hard this is an American thing
like I'm 12 Irish so St Patrick's Day
let's I'm kiss me if I'm you're not
Irish you're five generations of your
family have been in America you are
American now any other place you would
just be of that country but know
everybody identity politics has been
ingrained so hard into the West that
they feel the need to latch onto
something else because it's not
cool and woken in what culture it's not
cool to be American it's seen as bad
they hate capitalism they think
communism is good they latch onto and so
when you lose the identity of a place I
don't think it's worth living in if
there is no like no one you can't really
describe American culture now what is it
that's so true because everywhere so if
you go to California it's very different
from like Nebraska to Florida to New
York what do you think the future of
America is
like what happens if I move to Chicago
what's gonna I think you might it's just
have you seen the videos of that Chicago
suburbs so I live like like my parents
live on 40 acres outside the city so
it's not well I like cities I like busy
I like being around people I like people
but I just like look at Chicago's it's a
dump it's complete they just elected
like a new communist governor in in
Illinois or maybe the new mayor of
Chicago is just a straight up communist
they
are they're so brainwashed by racism and
wokeness and and how like it's okay if
you steal they're upset that's why
they're rioting you need to understand
the system of they are burning cars in
the middle of the street they've blocked
down streets and they're lighting cars
on fire and you're gonna say it's
because they're displaced that this is
Justified they they yeah they said they
can't just say that this is degenerate
Behavior like this they they won't
incriminate these people because they
are programmed to think that it's racist
to even criticize them my prediction for
the future of America
it's it's rapidly declining it's going
to exist but I think soon it's not going
to be the world power that it was and
America has pretty much been the world's
police for a long time and when you lose
that that grip on on the world like they
just reduce the military requirements
because people were too fat
the mill we're so fat that they needed
to make it easier to get in they had a
curve for your weight you know when the
teacher curves the score because
everyone failed that's how bad we are
with our fitness our military and then
you look at like they're training kids
in China like at 10 years old they're
getting ready for war in Russia they
don't have the same fat problem we don't
have that the thing is specifically in
the west and it's a big problem it's a
problem big problem the Obesity problem
the homelessness is going up
more kids are on pharmaceutical drugs I
was on them when people are I I don't I
don't see a bright future for America
unfortunately and I I do love America
like whatever is left of it some of some
of that culture I love the people that
love America but you have to put
yourself first at some point you know I
I believe in America first but I also
believe in family first before that so I
want to raise my family there oh where
where are you moving I like Florida is
like the was the last state I think
okay wait four okay
let me explain Florida Florida right now
Florida right now is is the last America
I didn't even finish I didn't I didn't
finish right now Florida's okay because
it's separated from that it's still good
weather they're signing some good laws
but eventually it's it's not going to be
a place long long term it's good for the
next 10 15 years 20 years something like
that eventually I don't know that's why
I'm traveling the world because I want
to go and see where it's it's worth
setting up tell me about your conversion
I mean Ramadan is almost over
but uh I don't even I'm gonna be honest
I know very little so I don't even know
what Ramadan is I've heard that it's
about a month of fasting and you have to
be an extra good Muslim you have to it's
mostly fasting and then some people that
you pray more you make sure to not drink
or it just all the same rules about are
extra strict during Ramadan it's an
extra connection
yeah it would say similar to Lynn okay
uh but I I didn't I mean like right now
I'm not sure what the time is you can
eat and you could break fast while
you're traveling but I wasn't perfect
editing it I wasn't perfect so when did
you convert and why
I converted in in Dubai I mean I guess
it was like a soft conversion but I did
say the words all you have to do to
convert to Islam and is say
um Muhammad is the prophet and allows
the one true God and then that's it in
other religions there's all this stuff
you need years of all this I said that I
went to the mosque I prayed
um shout out to the sartorial shooter he
brought me to the mall do they not do
they not believe in Jesus no I'm sorry
if these are dumb questions they're not
dumb questions yeah it's good to ask
these they they do believe in Jesus it's
actually Islamic Christianity have a lot
in common
um I would say the major difference and
what I think is kind of weird I grew up
you grew up Catholic there's some weird
stuff in Catholicism like no disrespect
but like the Father the Son the Holy
Spirit what the hell is the Holy Spirit
what is that that we do the sign across
all the time what's the Holy Spirit and
then you grow up and you take your first
communion you're eating the body of
Christ in a cracker
so is this cannibalism why am I eating a
cracker what part of the body of Jesus
is this is this the toe part of Jesus am
I eating is it the butt like I'm just
it's his body and then your kids are
drinking wine kids are getting drunk oh
no it doesn't matter it's the blood it's
wine yeah why are we giving kids alcohol
and you're drinking Jesus's blood you're
just a sip
it's a little Panic to be drinking a
dude's blood right yeah no but it's
Jesus I don't know it's just a little
weird to me but I'm not trying to be
disrespectful it's like a thousands
you're kind of reminding me how much of
a bad Catholic I am because I'm like I
like don't even remember the answer to
these questions I mean that's what it is
you're eating crackers that are his body
and you're drinking his blood there's
more to it it's like that's what it is I
grew up Catholic almost like that but
it's like that's what Jesus did at the
Last Supper it's like take this Jesus
ate his own body it was yeah sort of
weird I don't know if it was like type
of dude is in his body I mean well I
think and he's God at the same time
Christians in the Catholics so the
Christians say oh that was just symbol
I'm sorry the Catholics are going to
roast me I'm a bad Catholic I don't know
what to tell you but the the Catholics
believe like like we actually yeah
yeah well I grew up Catholic I guess the
hardcore there's a lot of division there
but
you know that in the Quran they talk
more about Jesus than Muhammad Jesus is
uh is brought up all the time he's not
actually God though that's the
difference in Catholicism why it didn't
really make sense to me because how
could you be a human and God Catholics
believe that Jesus is God and God is God
but they're the same like Father the Son
it's like this weird that doesn't make
any sense to me but in Islam the reason
that I converted is Allah is the one
true God that's the one that's the
creator of the universe the creator of
Everything Jesus was there to spread his
message Muhammad was a prophet and then
we are all his people we are all his
creation and that just makes the most
sense to me because like what's the best
explanation for why the world exists
there must be a Creator but instead of
like a human half body eating yeah that
is a little confusing I that's why I
like it's just there's one Creator and
also the really strict and on their
beliefs on masculinity and femininity on
the differences between men and women
and our roles and what we should be
doing
I went to the mosque and I was with um
some some well-respected people in the
Islamic community I don't want to say
who I was with them and and after the
first time praying there you get on the
rug and you know you do all that and I
asked him when we were leaving I'm like
why are there no women here like I
didn't even I never thought about them
before I was on the mosque and like I
never noticed that like there's no women
here and then I asked him that question
he looked at me like I was stupid like
they're at home they're cooking like why
would they they don't need they pray at
home they don't need to be here this is
the men's job to go out and provide and
to go and but they don't they're not and
I never even realize that they don't
that they're not there because the
division between men and women is
extremely important respected and it's
ingrained in the culture but that's not
the same in in any of these other
religions
true and a lot of um Christian and I
would say in Catholic religions
though they're in charge yeah happy wife
happy life yeah um what's the other one
she wears the pants I mean I I heard
that all the time growing up she wears
the pants in the relationship like there
were so many couples that I can point to
and say yeah that's and they'd be like
oh shoot I gotta ask the wife she wears
the pants and they're oh yeah
well it's yeah it's like in the in
America and I'll say like I think this
definitely affected me it's like men and
women are kind of raised the same and
they don't really talk about our
differences and even like being in in
sports you know that's like a typically
like male dominated like you know men
are better at sports right really
no now
let's get them out good thing you got
out of volleyball now you'd be destroyed
by Dylan Mulvaney
actually I think you could beat him up I
think he got it I actually rejoined the
team after I told you I quit hey yeah
but yeah we'll see we'll see but but
what I realized is like
a lot of times like the women in sports
are a little bit more masculine because
we're kind of like being trained and
it's competitive yeah yeah and that's
what I realized like I think women like
we are happier when they they push our
differences but the thing is in America
they they act like we're exactly
why not do that the big wake-up call was
going to Japan and seeing and you have
to go you have to go just to see how the
women act because this is a big part of
your show and I think it would give you
a new perspective
the women there don't have a drop of
testosterone in their body like the they
just the way that they smile the way
that they talk to you how high pitched
their voices
it's like whoa and it's just so nice
it's just so soothing and pleasant like
you order something oh okay okay
and you're like ah and you just and you
just you just want to protect them just
naturally you you're you feel more like
a man because you want to protect and
you want to provide for her you just
want to create that nice environment for
this for this beautiful feminine woman
and then you realize they're like amount
the amount
of [__] that you need to put up with
with these women in America and London
how combative they are and how hard it
is for them to submit like it's not in
their nature at all everything in the
culture is steering them away from being
feminine it's like it's like now you
this it's just the cardi B thing you
need to be the Tip-Top guy in order to
make a woman submit but women are happy
to just do that in Japan the way that
they dress they're just way more girly
and not in like an overly sexual way
none of them have their cleavage out
they're always
um have they're not showing too much
like skin they but they dress extremely
girly with their dresses and their
fingernails and like someone was walking
around with cat ears because it's Goofy
and you I you you see there like
why am I putting up with women who want
to be men at the same time when you
could just go to a different place and
find an actually feminine woman
you understand why so many guys are are
just or just giving up yeah you get it
like and even now the the guys who are
becoming women in the west like they
just want you see the types of guys that
they that they want and they're like
yeah I just eat a stud like I need an
ultra they just want to get [__] they
just want someone else to take a troll
it's a relinquishing control because
it's so hard to be in control when what
you all it's a constant battle
but they want someone else to take
control and just just let the work you
know I give up it's just giving up it's
not it's not feeling like a woman it's
just like [__] man no I hate this and I
think it's even good for American women
to see it because it gives us an example
which a lot of women in the west don't
have like what what feminine women
examples do we have in media what
feminine like even most orianna Ariana
Grande I think is a pretty good example
there's very few
I mean
you really get the I don't I'm not I
don't know much about her there's very
few there's very few but the way she
acts she's kind of she kind of Acts in
everything like she covers her her wrist
she's like he yeah she kind of acts like
that
taught an episode of wife school and she
was like teaching me like cooking
basically right and I was so inspired
just being around her to be just
spending a day with her because she was
just so like the most feminine woman
I've ever met in my life and I think
that like in the west a lot of times
especially people from single parent
homes they've never met someone like
that
and it's not all those the women it's
not their fault either a lot of the time
it's the weak men like women can't be in
their feminine nature if they're around
a bunch of but why are the men weak
because the women are masculinized too
it's it's when you when you act like
there's no division when you separate
the idea that we're different I have a
different taste what's your take so my
take is it's the government because of
the way that relationships are set up by
the government and I think that's why so
if me and you are in a contract right if
we're if we're married right and I get
paid to walk away and you lose
everything by walking away you're always
going to be trying to make me happy so I
don't walk away
I think that influences relationships
and I think that's the shift where you
see in relationships where women started
like wearing the pants yeah we don't
disagree but there's many factors like
that that's a major factor uh the music
that we listen to Media uh it's it's
everything it's just Western culture
it's all of it there's the separate like
not having any identity people are
always arguing and people the beliefs
that we have everything is steering Us
in that direction my other question
in Japan why are the women still so
unmarried in single school there I know
it's a big problem so it's like
what are the size on that I don't you
may look it up I can sure okay but it's
like it's like um
there's a lot of single women in Japan
yeah I didn't see that when I went there
I heard a lot of rumors about Japan like
they they talked about how creepy it was
like one thing that people hear is that
they sell girls panties and vending
machines I didn't see that
um they talked about how how many single
like how creepy guys are on the train I
didn't see I was on the train every
single day there wasn't any any creepy
stuff like that and you actually will
see it in New York you'll see people
smoking on the train and taking a piss
in the corner but Japan is not like that
Japan I don't know I just know that
they're the birth rates declining Japan
yeah Japan leads the world in childless
middle-aged women it leads the world in
childless middle-aged women yeah the
birth rate is the climate because
they're over they're overworking
themselves right now the work the work
culture is really strong and that's what
happens in an industrialized Society
they will that's just natural
um yeah women without children at 50
years old is almost 30 percent am I
crazy that's more what is it in America
uh 20 or UK oh this one doesn't have
America I'm sorry this is you no us is
15 here wow it's raising a lot too yeah
no I just wonder why because I believe
you that the women are better they are
yeah like why better they're definitely
more feminine yeah so I just I just
wonder like why they're having a lot of
the same issues so you think they're
overloaded due to difficulty getting
married a preference not to have
children because there are putting off
having children or due to infertility
and I met there's a girl there's a
there's a girl on my team from Japan
um and she's having the same I mean
she's here now but she's was raised
there and she was like 36 or 37.
cheese I think this is this happens in
First World countries it goes up and
down like I think there'll be a boom
soon but it seems like it's a financial
problem for the most part like these
guys are overworked and they they really
want it to be perfect for them to start
having kids they want everything they
need to be married and there's no hookup
culture there so I went to Japan you
know I was younger you did when I was 12
my mom sent me on a
Japan by yourself yeah who'd you stay
with
um some friend that she had in high
school and what was your experience
um well they didn't really they didn't
really like me I'm gonna be honest when
I was 12. yeah because I don't think my
mom told them that I was coming I think
there was some miscommunication so I
just ended up with this random lady in
Japan but my impression was that the
kids worked super hard like that they
only had like two weeks of summer school
I remember the technology was better and
I hated the food back then which is a
shame because I love Japanese food now
but yeah I was only 12. so you know what
do you do what do you what do you really
look at when you're 12. yeah it's
interesting that's that makes me uh
think I didn't that wasn't what I saw
I saw a lot of families but
yeah there's got to be something to
overworking the population like that
do you think you sue what you see
no because
but I also
I also want to see it away everyone's
like world view influences how they see
the world but it's also like one thing
you'll you won't really see in Japan is
uh dogs the Japanese people that they I
saw way more kids than I saw dogs but in
the west like in Miami a lot in New York
you'll see way more young people walking
around dogs like even dogs in a stroller
dog in a purse rather than have kids
because they would rather be a dog mom
how do you date in this modern era it's
so interesting people that are a little
bit like more traditional minded do you
date in a traditional I'm hypocritical
too we talked about the hypocrisy in the
conservative world uh like I just
converted to Islam like you know I I
have multiple girlfriends which is Haram
you know you're supposed to wait until
marriage and but you have to find ways
to navigate the world that's in front of
you like when the Quran was written
stuff like that we didn't have woke
garbage we didn't have this
indoctrinated world so you have to find
you have to pick and choose
I would like to be a good Muslim
eventually but you know I still drink
yeah I'm not perfect but I told you to
go sober with me remember you said you
would I did yeah on that stream yes yes
I did a stream with you yes yes I did a
stream with you in Miami and I said like
that you would go sober and then you
told the chat you would go sober with me
for how long it was like a month or
something oh I definitely didn't do it
yeah no I know and then it was like two
days later you're like yeah I can't do
that yeah I can't I can't I can but I I
quit weed it then yeah I mean we all
have our battles it's like if I had to
quit sugar tomorrow I don't even see it
as a battle it's just like I I enjoy it
yeah I just you know like uh later
tonight I'm gonna go out with some some
of my friends and it's just just make
social situations more enjoyable
um
but you know eventually it could be
better but that's the way I see it to
navigate as a man is to
see that your attention and your time is
the most valuable thing you have uh and
women are incentivized to take advantage
of your time and attention and to to
pretty much ruin your life like women
will destroy men if you look at any good
man like you'll see how soul-crushing it
is when they get involved with one woman
and who's not elevating you is not
pushing you forward so in my opinion the
best way is to have multiple girlfriends
and then they pretty much worship you uh
they're in love with you and you like
the girls I talk to like I'll text them
like once a day or something like that
and see them maybe once a month
something like that but they they value
that time so much that it's worth not
seeing other people and that's the best
way I've I've noticed for it to stay
focused I've tried
um that investment I've made mistakes
like
starting a business with a girlfriend
like getting her like oh yeah let's like
be a team like we're a partner it's like
what like this is never gonna work it's
a waste of your time and
it's better to just have them they live
their life and don't live with them
don't live with their girlfriend
especially like if you're a young man
it's better to keep it separate to work
as much as you can and get to that high
that high level status because
like if I'm if I'm here having
a struggling and dating you know
Rich well-known status all the stuff
like that that would check all the boxes
for women and it's still like I'm still
navigating it like imagine what it's
like for the average guy so it's better
to focus on becoming
um as high status and as wealthy as
possible
and learning all these social situations
and understanding women before you get
invested into a long-term relationship
in the west I think it's easier to find
a wife in other places Eastern Europe
places that have culture but if you're
in the west like
you better just focus on yourself and
keep that separate do you want like 10
suns are you gonna go that route
I want a big family yeah I want a big
family but you always notice that guys
like me end up having daughters have you
noticed that that's what made me believe
in God is that all the all the
womanizers just God punishes you with
like seven daughters in a row and then
all the all the faithful guys they end
up having Sons because God's rewarding
them you were good you have a couple
Sons good job you didn't you were
monogamous you didn't but I I think that
God will will punish me with uh with a
couple daughters
I was thinking my dad was 50 50 so so
what's your sibling ratio well three
were like out of the biological ones
um it's uh four girls three boys
and then they we adopted uh so he was
cheating a little bit no no no no
no maybe in past relationships or
something like that no it's crazy my
parents have all
there no way yeah that's what they they
met yeah they met with my mom was like
they've been together forever when did
they meet how old are they my mom oh
sorry my mom was 18 we'll say
um
but he was he was five years older
so yeah I'll be a groomer nowadays but
no he was a good guy and my dad was um
he's like a nerd you know so you know
back then women actually valued the
Nerds and saw potential in them you know
where nowadays like I don't think women
would give my dad a second look or like
men like my dad because they're not like
you know on Instagram a lot of social
media like a smooth talk with all that
stuff but like you know he's he's a good
a good man you know yeah I don't think
women really value social media to that
level it's good to like get in the door
to find girls but I don't think women
care
actually I don't think women care at all
I think women kind of respect you more
if you're more mysterious and you don't
have that type of presence and like
who's this guy really I just see what a
check mark does to guys and like I have
not experienced this right I mean to be
honest like I I've had the Checkmate
maybe maybe I'm wrong I don't know I
have not it's it for me and they don't
talk about this in the red but it's been
pretty much all about character okay how
you carry yourself in my experience the
fame has not really it does help it does
help like if you go to a club and she's
like I've seen you before it's pretty
you know but
when it comes to that first interaction
the blue check doesn't really
never really did much I don't know my
point more I just think
for like men with
like data so like I just think in my
mom's situation when she was young like
she valued character first what to find
him as a nerd
if you mad at me
gaming like what is it like sports fan
glasses no no he's just an engineer okay
so smart or nerdy no my dad's super
smart he's like uh I don't think it was
too are the same
I would say to nerd like the 40 year old
guy who still has a bunch of Mars no no
he's not like that he's my Star Wars
collection I don't think of it as a bad
thing my dad's just the type of guy to
like program for like 10 hours or figure
out stuff in his business for like 10 12
hours
um yeah I don't think your mom ever saw
him as nerdy she saw him as ambitious
probably
I don't know
I don't know but
yeah she told me she liked him because
he was fun too but my point guards
aren't fun
nerds aren't fun okay maybe the nerd is
the wrong word yeah just a smart guy
yeah it's not flashy yeah I just don't
think like
I don't know I think nowadays I don't
you know you always hear about like
women overlooking like certain guys in
high school or whatever and then they
like come back later like I feel like
that's kind of like my dad or like
certain I don't know oh like that Meme
where like the girl sleeping with the
bad guy yeah she's pregnant five years
later yeah where did all the good guys
go and he's rich now that was him yeah
I don't know but
I don't wanna I don't want to put my dad
that was interesting it's fun to see
Pearl's background Yeah well yeah
because
um my I'm one of seven kids and my
parents they um well biological so I
grew up the second to six but yeah and
then um like they adopted three
teenagers so it's kind of crazy
backstory where'd they find the
teenagers
um one was homeless and my brother's
football team and they took him in um
one and then one had an alcoholic mom
they took her in and then one had
um abusive parents and they took him in
were they all white
uh yes oh okay
because I knew some um some white
families that adopted back in high
school and they would adopt like some
black people and it was just like just
funny you know no like I have a black
brother like do you you know like like
The Blind Side yeah it was kind of like
that like what is this I don't know I I
just I think that's that's two or two
were like my second cousins or something
so two were related to me and then one
um was a rando yeah one was just on my
brother's football team it was kind of
weird because I came back from college
and he was just like there and I'm like
who's this hey he's your brother well we
didn't call him they just said this is
Chaz and I was like oh hi Chaz so was he
ever legally about how old was he when
he was adopted like 16 so then he was
just crashing at your place yeah but he
still comes to Christmas and stuff yeah
like he still lives at my parents house
how old is he like 23. oh you gotta get
out of there well he's in school I don't
know he he just found a good family
he's crashing you found a good situation
yeah how are how are stuff with your
family I know things were like kind of
Rocky the last time it wasn't Rocky it
was just um we
it's difficult for them like they're I
would say my parents seem kind of
similar to yours and so there are but
like they're always on the internet like
oh like reading all the stuff and then
okay calm down
um yeah I recently saw them and it was
great it was great to hang out with them
and I got to do
I don't want to I got to
show them
the fruits of my labor you know and it
was good to be like hey you know I'm not
some bum here we go you know does that
make sense yeah how did because I I know
you didn't go home for Christmas right
no no can I ask you about this or yeah I
was just wondering like how did you
reconcile that it's it's all it's all
good now it's just like the ideological
differences was um was tough to to
balance but everything yeah everything's
good now good I'm glad to hear it yeah
yeah family families are the number one
important thing
um but like my my advice for people
watching is like just try to separate
those
political differences in those those
ideologies you know like if you can
disagree and still tolerate somebody and
still respect their company
um I think the past three years it
became extremely polarizing with covid
and and the V word all this stuff was
like just people were just like huh it's
just like a lot of time
and Trump is another one yeah it's just
people did not know how to communicate
properly but everything everything's
everything's good now we gotta talk
about these reaction channels that bully
you
that's what I wanna I wanted to bring
out bully I think they bully you
I mean I don't have YouTube so I don't
have the opportunity to defend myself on
the same platform like when I even get
in these types of YouTube drama
people like all the literally every
single streamer every single one will
react to the videos against me and then
I drop my response
silence
they never it's disingenuous well and
I'm really tired of them throwing this
three-way thing in your face all right
I'm so tired of that that's all they
ever bring up again I mean that's all
they have when I told that story I knew
it was an embarrassing story and I
thought of it as like as a way to give
them something when I take it back yeah
man I think that that gives me more
validity as somebody who's speaking all
the time and like why when people call
me like a grifter I'm like no I've
clearly shown that I'm willing to be
vulnerable and honest and tell
embarrassing stories
um you know the first time I interviewed
you when you told me about the three-way
thing I was like I honestly thought it
was sweet because I was like oh he's
going to the like such extreme lengths
to make her happy
oh
no it was it was guilt it was guilt it
was like you know but that's never gonna
flip that they're gonna clip it
that's never gonna that I'm never
probably going to live down no that's
gonna be ammunition forever but I I mean
it used to bother me used to get like
[__] like these [__] uh I was just
being honest it was an embarrassing
story but it's just like man [__] it
like because they just throw it like
you'll be making art it just irritates
me because you'll be making an argument
about a a b or c and they'll be like but
the three-way or whatever it was called
the the party the swinger party and
you'll be like hey
swinger party and you'll be like B and
they'll be like yeah it's a good way to
deflect from the conversation but I mean
that's that's social media yeah it
really used to like it was like [__]
like to seeing but now if you look at
any time I tweet there's just all these
memes of uh all these cuck memes people
have notifications on just to like
different they photoshop my face and I I
kind of find it funny now like all the
big meme accounts on Twitter like if I
say anything they'll just
um but I think they bully you I think
they bully fresh and Fit I think they I
don't like don't use that word bully
they just they're seeking attention
they're just using our names what's
wrong with these word bully because
bullying implies that it hurts oh okay
or like that it has an effect or that
bullying is like a guy giving you a
wedgie and putting your face in the
toilet and giving you a swirly like
that's yeah is he [__] are you
serious these people
that's true it's it's but this is this
is what they have like they they don't
add anything to the conversation that's
new they don't have anything that they
stand for their entire persona is just
like talking down to other people they
don't have any point of view so they
need us they need us to exist that's not
bullying that's a leech you know looking
to find a clip like they're gonna do
this with this interview there's gonna
be something probably something with the
repeal the 19th probably something with
the Japan thing there's going to be a
video like sneako advocates for
and then they'll just use that and then
get their content they're eating off of
what I'm like me trying to add something
new to the conversation I don't see it
as bullying I just see it as the chain
of command can you explain that more
they don't exist without us yeah can you
break that down
their whole thing reacting they don't
have a point of view they don't stand
for anything they don't believe in
anything they're not trying to seek
anything like I'll be making a point a
like you said yeah swinger party like
it's just reacting to to us it's it's
leeching off of somebody else it's like
riding someone else's coattails even
though they're saying negative things
you are still writing our coattails
because I've seen channels where
literally six videos in a row sneako new
sneako thing it's just not I'm talking
about Ava and preach not even them I'm
not I'm not even talking about them
there's so many of them yeah I don't I
don't want to give this guy because like
if you think about it see it there's a
name
you don't even know who this is oh I
don't know I you probably don't know who
this is okay but it's it's really funny
to me that I I won't say their name that
they're they really desperately want
they want it so bad because they would
give them something to like yeah and
then make a whole video but I can like
hold you I can just dangle this power
like let me just not do it well they
just find something to argue with
like that's all they're doing is they're
looking for any like just anything that
they can it's not even an argument it's
it's trying to tarnish your reputation
because that's what YouTube incentivizes
incentivizes drama content YouTube when
I started and why I want to bring art
back and and make something new it used
to be like a new creation people like
Nigahiga like it'd be creative there'd
be something different uh YouTube put
like crazy montages new editing Styles
YouTube used to be a creative space and
then this algorithm thing started where
everybody is trying to get pushing the
algorithm so hard and you need to stay
relevant you need to have a ton of watch
time so it does not incentivize you to
make a five minute creative video which
is what I was doing it doesn't it
doesn't push that it's hard to make
money off of that but everybody want to
make money off of it want influence and
wants attention so it's drama content
it's content that you watch for an out
like an hour-long Pearl the Deep die and
that's like a crazy face of you looking
like the truth about Pearl and then it's
just this mindless entertainment people
will watch you oh hey Pearl who and then
they see you in public what do they do
hey Pearl well that the same people that
come up to you and take selfies are
watching videos of like tarnishing
reputation because it makes them feel
better about being failures it makes
them feel better about not doing
anything they see somebody who's doing
something who's saying something new
who's trying to push the conversation
forward and making money doing out here
making their own content and they need
they need to feel Justified that they're
not doing it so that's what it pushes
now it pushes drama content YouTube it
it's just bad documentaries it's
[__] on people there's not a lot of
creative people so when those people
come along when somebody with a voice
comes along everybody's there trying to
pull and trying to get a piece of the
pie because like why risk your
reputation why risk telling a story the
risk being authentic telling an
embarrassing story uh when you can
protect your own reputation you know you
could just be this like faceless person
and all you do is criticize it it's it's
better to do that you'll make more money
you'll get more views will you have fans
no are you gonna add anything new no but
you'll make more money and so like can
you blame them I don't blame them I mean
if I had nothing to add if I didn't want
to risk you know putting my reputation
on the line
I'd probably do the same type of videos
you're like inspiring me a little bit
right now thank you yeah because I'm
like it goes back I feel like what I
like about you is you're so unafraid to
like tell like even the the freaking
three-way store I would die with that
secret that happened to me like yeah I'm
a completely authentic person yeah and I
think people value that that's like why
I will have longevity and while even
though I'm banned I'm still generating
so many views for these people on a
platform that I'm banned on because I'm
actively seeking truth or funny like
people see me as somebody malleable
somebody that's actively thinking
engaging in conversations and that's
rare because everybody needs to act like
they know everything even the reaction
channels they they put themselves at on
a moral High Ground like look at these
red pillars because they don't want to
risk changing their worldview there's
not a lot of people on the platform on
social media who are like coming with a
like oh let me just try to find things
out you you come in with an angle of
curiosity which is rare because people
don't want to like even right now like
you mess up the word assimilate and
immigrate and you're like oh that was
system but people don't ever want to put
themselves in that situation because
they don't they need to seem like they
know everything and it's disingenuous
but humans are always learning even even
the stream we did it was like me you and
Destiny and I'll I'll just be like yeah
I'm dumb but I don't mean it but it's
just like I hate it when people act like
they know everything so I'm just like
yeah I'm an idiot now what you know but
then it's like hard because the reaction
channel is like yeah yeah and they clip
freaking everything and I feel like like
I've been on longer I get more like
nervous to tell stories or whatever
because I'm just like they've just
started to like clippy and put things
together in a way to like say things
that I didn't say and so it's actually
like inspiring to talk to you because
you don't give a [__] you just have to
let them because that's yeah that's the
chain of command like yeah you you're
growing something they're taking their
little nibbles it's like a a mosquito or
like a little worm and an apple like
getting their piece getting their food
people don't like but have you ever ever
encountered a hater in real life
like I I get maybe someone in public
like you call them but like someone
who'd be like I hate you Pearl uh like
once or two not much not much what was
it it was I was recruiting at a Chris
Brown concert
um so we were recruiting like girls for
the show and there's I mean it wasn't
anything crazy she was just like oh not
you yeah
but you came up to her first yeah yeah
yeah okay like oh I know who you like
but nobody has approached you okay
that's what I mean like these people
it's not I understand like when you're
in the space and you see these videos
like you want to protect your image and
your reputation but that's the that's
the nature of the game that's how they
silence people who are trying to who are
trying to add something new to the
conversation that is they try to go at
your reputation because they have
nothing else even the Nick interview I
did like that was honestly one I'm it's
going up yeah it's gonna go up um it was
one of my favorite videos I've done
because I just learned so much in it and
I know they're gonna clip this and like
do whatever with it but like genuinely I
think he's a nice guy you can't be
afraid of them because then then the C
is away from us having a conversation
right now yeah and then us now we're
thinking about how they're gonna go in
no and that's what I realized that like
I'm trying to I'm trying to yeah I'm
here how they'll pull the like it's so
funny because you'll start to hear it in
your head yeah how they're gonna pull
clips and you're like oh no even though
I was thinking that this this yeah even
when I was talking to you about my dad
I'm like I don't want to say anything
that they're gonna clip and make my dad
look bad you know because it's like I
love the same thing when you ask about
like the Christmas thing I'm like oh
there we go there's gonna be oh I mean
we can cut it yeah you can keep it in
but but like my my way of approaching
this and advice for people watching is
just approach it if you have a pure
heart and if you're a genuine person you
have nothing to fear like they'll try to
tarnish your reputation but and one of
the big turning points I saw
was working with Mr Beast like
2017-2018.
I remember when I met these guys Chris
especially the guy
they were shooting AK-47s they had guns
in their thumbnails they were making
edgy jokes and like oh I identify as an
attack helicopter I'm 30 genders they're
making like edgy jokes and then Mr Beast
is business-minded you know he wants to
be number one YouTuber so he you don't
want to give him any ammunition let me
not give the woke mob anything to take
me down for I'm going to be as
unproblematic as possible you stop
cursing then he takes guns out of the
thumb imagine a Mr Beast video with an
AK-47 now it's just like Orbeez and pool
balls but when I was working that's what
it was I remember I had this joke we
were like building a mansion for with
boxes and I was making jokes about Trump
building a wall stuff like that he would
never see that joke now they even had
like masculine guys when I was working
they fired them all and you replace them
with like Fruity guys
um don't say that respectfully but
that's who's on the cast now and so when
Chris is working like when I when I met
him he was like saying some jokes saying
some misogyny he was just like a
southern guy driving the truck with the
hat I remember this guy I spent a lot of
time with him and then seeing him now is
the result of what happens when you're
afraid of the woke mob when you let them
win when you are afraid of criticism
when you live for the social media
algorithm you will become the social
media algorithm
how do you get such thick skin because
like I felt like I had thick skin in the
beginning but I just feel like the
longer I'm on it's like hard I don't
know how you do it yeah like it's gonna
naturally be harder
I mean
yeah it's a lot it had to have bothered
you at some point right or never but
this is what I do is I I just show I see
it as uh Free Press
I'm giving away the sauce right now but
how did Trump win the election in 2016.
oh his media coverage he would just he
would say things to like trigger the
media it worked and then we talk about a
Non-Stop but Trump was completely dead
set on his philosophy he loves America
and so no matter what they say he's
going to connect with the real people
mainstream news tried to lie about him
Russian misinformation he's a misogynist
he grabbed her by the whatever they try
to lie about him but the people can see
through that I see all the reaction
channels as the CNN of YouTube they're
just trying to it's it's pretty much the
same thing like look at what Pearl said
today new clip good knew this and then
people you know the people will watch it
for entertainment but they don't really
believe it so I'm banned and they can't
stop talking about me
am I living genuine to what I believe in
am I traveling the world am I living a
good life am I training every single day
am I meeting incredible people all over
the world am I happy yeah so all this
stuff is just people talking about my
name Non-Stop
kind of found a hack in the system
because I'm supposed to be silenced I'm
off of YouTube twitch Tick Tock all and
they can't stop talking about me so as
long as I do not let them affect me and
if I don't go down stoop to their level
I'm winning I'm just getting free press
it depends on how you react to it so
when you get all the cancellation type
stuff and when they try to the drama
content they will look at you under a
microscope and as long as you're living
genuine to what you believe in then
you're gonna you're gonna get some
you're gonna get more fans people are
going to respect you more the the way
that I get around that is paying close
attention to how they're really looking
at your reaction to all this and if you
can if you can beat them then you will
have longevity longer than they will you
inspiring me a little bit I'm like maybe
we should make more original content and
less reactions yeah I I think
conversations are good and this is why I
like you know the hypocrisy I I blew up
a lot doing react like doing streams
reacting to stuff of course I try to add
my own spin on it add my own comedy but
you know it how different is it than the
other kind so but I want to separate
myself from that I want to really Ascend
to the next level because I want to be
in this Echo chamber of like oh there's
roads but forever it's just it's garbage
so what projects do you have coming up I
don't have any projects coming up none I
mean I have interviews lined up and um
going to continue traveling the world
but
the way that I create is um a lot of
time through traveling and new
experiences being around different
people it just it comes
organically I don't like planning things
out
if I want to plan it out too much then
it takes away that that that Curiosity
and that fun aspect it needs to be fun
like if it ever feels like a chore if it
feels like work I that's when I noticed
the uh the artistic aspect is taken away
but if I if I'm really passionate about
it then
that's when I create something different
tell me about you had a tweet and I
can't remember exactly what it was but
it was about Japan and it was like about
it being
a very similar Society of something with
race mixing I don't remember what I said
exactly but
Japan is and I I guess some of these
stats of the birth rate and stuff like
that like they
um you know it could be higher right now
but the way that it's run and the way
that the people act and treat each other
is pretty much the America that Nick
Fuentes wants low immigration
imaginative Society conservative
everybody votes for the same party that
you know you know that there's no like
culture war in Japan it's exhausting
coming back because you realize like how
Polaroid people can't even decide on a
gender and then over there everybody
votes for the same party they believe in
the same thing they just want to work
and enjoy food have fun they want to
live a good life so they all vote for
the same it's been the same party for
like 50 years in Japan so that that's
pretty much like the America that like
Fuentes wants and I see that as as the
only solution
I don't see uh this like every four
years someone else we put the president
in jail uh
I don't see that any longevity in the
west of if we keep it like that I think
that you actually need
to some extent I think you need a
dictator to save America the way Putin's
been in charge of Russia for like 20
years
that's that's the only way to and a lot
of Russia most of Russia is pretty happy
with Putin they like him there was like
some controversy for a couple years but
they liked the way that he's running it
um the every the two-party system it's
just there's too much infighting and it
it makes everybody how do they do it
it's one party where in Japan in Russia
I don't in Russia it's been Putin's a
dictator and he's been the place for
dictatorships I'm not I wouldn't like I
will I'm not playing
no I'm not pro dictator but it's just
it's working in Russia I mean how is it
working
they hold on to their Christian values
and they're stopping I gotta I gotta
tell you something when I saw that arms
dealer that they let out you know what
I'm talking about I watched this
interview with him and I'm like is he
based like yeah yeah there's a video and
he's talking about how America is not
the same America anymore they've lost
their values and I was like this arms
dealer that's like supposed to be
horrible sounded amazing yeah you know
who's really bass and I recommend people
like actually read his Manifesto
and it's like and then you get somebody
who's speaking your message of Truth and
we put them in jail for three months
without any charges uh and anybody who's
still saying like oh their traffickers
their human traffickers look do you do
you want to live oh like how do you want
to live in a society where under the
suspicion of a crime you can go to jail
for three months while they go and
search for evidence that alone is such a
very obvious idea very blatant
corruption
and ultimate and people turn their head
about it and they and they still like
well he's bald what is wrong with you
there's no evidence of anything they're
looking for the evidence so that you can
be put in jail to look for evidence for
three months if you get nervous that'll
happen to you no no I I don't live in
fear I don't I don't live it but that's
what happens at a certain level of
influence they need to do something
about it same thing happen to Trump
right now so
um for people that don't know like we're
talking about Andrew Tate so what
when did your friendship start with him
I mean I went to Bucharest uh in
November I would say uh I'm a little bit
closer with Tristan than Andrew but yeah
I mean they saw my content stuff like
that and I did some talked to Tristan on
stream a couple times and we get along
and then we hung around hung out on
Bucharest and then uh yeah we were
planning like right before the uh they
got locked up we were planning a stream
but it's a little bit difficult now and
we're all these women just
having a horrible time just being you
were there that was it was just like
really eye-opening because you see that
was a perfect example how you see one
narrative pushed on social media and
then you see in real life and it's just
very obviously not true and you see how
many people believe in a lie and I
understand like some people are still
trying to argue it like well they
actually this is well sore source you
point blank period you should not be put
in jail under the suspicion of a crime
like imagine like all these people that
are criticizing they do drugs right
that's a crime should you be put in jail
while the police search your apartment
for drugs and then they find it is that
a society you want to live in like well
I am committing okay if you actually are
committing a crime right now you should
be put in jail and wait till they find
the weed in your apartment make it fair
if you think that these people should be
put in jail why they go and search for
something that doesn't exist well and
why don't people believe the people that
were actually there
because you actually went to his his
Mansion right yeah and there were so
many people that actually went to his
mansion and said no the women are are
good like why why don't people believe
you guys because
our world view
trumps their entire world view like if
we are right then their existence and
their entire ideology makes no sense so
they don't actually think that these
people are evil they don't think Andrew
interested are evil but them existing
just corrupts their
everything they talk about corrupts
their philosophy so they need them to be
silenced it just it makes them feel
better it's cold they need them to be
bad people so that they can feel better
about what they're talking about they
know that they're not nobody actually
thinks that they're guilty of anything
that even the people I don't want to say
their names anymore because but
they know that they're they know that
they're we all know they know they're
innocent yeah but they they need them to
be in jail so they can keep on streaming
on switch
and I think it's a shame because
it's just like if that can happen to
Andrew or guy what's going to happen to
you too
that could happen it can't happen and
it's even they've it's been close with a
lot of people that are still hating and
accusing it's a giant warning sign for
men and still people actively turn their
head to it and act like this is not
possible like oh some women will accuse
you and you could be put in jail while
they go and look for the evidence of it
that is a crazy world to live in and I'm
saying that now and it's very possible
that it could happen to me
that's it's not an unrealistic thing to
talk about that they could just put me
in jail because some girl said something
without any evidence
thank you so much for coming today
thanks for having me on we left on a
dark tone but it's it's a warning sign
this is this is what I want to say you
want to move to Chicago I'm saying for
for anybody watching
I think it's best to make as much money
as possible
to start an online business and then be
able to go to different places so that
you're not trapped so that you're not
under constant surveillance so you're
not under constant threat of somebody
ruining your life because they are
telling you that that men are evil and I
I care about women equally
um as I care about men like we talk
about
because women will be happier if they're
in their feminist State raising children
and staying home yeah tell me tell me
where should I move what should I what
should I do I don't know what should I
do with my life I don't know that's why
I'm going to continue traveling the
world training working hard can you give
me Spark Notes after your let me know
after my travels yeah yeah well I'm
about to go to South America and then
I'm going to Eastern Europe um in a
couple days so I'm going to continue
seeing the world and then figure that
out but if if you are
critically analyzing the chessboard
there is absolutely no reason
no real reason to stay in the west other
than my family's there yeah that's it
culturally no
family-wise no quality of life no taxes
like you think okay because my one
question is you don't think that like
when you have because my family's pretty
like well off so you don't think it's a
bit of a bubble when you have money in
the west a bubble for you because it's
like even okay yeah Chicago is bad but
we live on 40 acres in the I don't I
don't think you should care like that's
like the white guilt like when you say
that like oh should I live shitty with
people in Chicago because I have money
no no I just met like my parents built
like
so my parents have a 10 bedroom house
and they bought a whole neighborhood for
me and my siblings to like live in
you know
and so it's like that's I don't know
that's where everyone's from that's
where everyone I know is so why why is
it bad to live in a bubble no it's not
so that's why I was saying like even if
you stay in the west like isn't it
different if you have money that's true
yeah that's true but you're gonna have a
harder time like the average person
watching this is not going to have that
scenario right right no you said that to
me why would I go to Chicago oh yeah
there you go yeah you can and you're not
going to be put in jail for some men
falsely accusing you you're just going
to get some hit pieces from nerds from
some reaction that's it and they're like
twice my age
all the people making videos about us
are much older than us it's very funny
you imagine being like in your mid-40s
talking about a bunch of 20 year olds
look at this clip I founded this guy
half my age like bro what like you
really people really watch this
I'm like you guys are so grown how are
you still doing this I have empathy for
them like this this is their life like I
don't want to be that yeah at that age
I'm gonna be I want to be out of here I
don't want to be doing much bigger
things than that so hey man I I genuine
you you call it bullying I genuinely
look at it with empathy like this is
your your livelihood you need me you
need pearl without what are you gonna
talk about without it so just let them
have it let it genuinely like next time
they do it you should be oh look at oh I
needed this comp everyone here needed
yeah that's okay this has been a crazy
like oh my gosh oh the colonizer oh
that's so cute oh you think I'm oh silly
reaction Channel you group oh I love you
well you know what's crazy it's like the
same people that would say they were so
worried about the people
which is more racist than anything like
to even bring slavery into this while
people are like enjoying life and
working yeah making money it's just just
just uh you're a little wokey
let him let him have it what what do you
believe in can you specify that a little
bit you always say that the reaction
channels don't stand for anything they
don't believe in anything so what do you
believe in what do you stand for I
believe in what I'm trying to be a
better Muslim and believe in God more
and I believe in creation
I I think I outlined it on this podcast
I think that men are at their happiest
when we are creating when we are
creating something new if you create a
business or if you use for me it's
creating art
um
adding something to the world creating
life starting a family those are that's
where we derive our happiness from uh
and these people they're not really
creating they're just responding and so
I don't think that's a happy existence I
think that just like being someone a
talking head I don't like this I don't
see that as a as a happy existence just
trying to to bring other people down I
believe in progress I believe in like
always moving forward uh never if you
stay stagnant that's where I get
uncomfortable I need to constantly be
evolving growing uh becoming better
and that's how I think Society functions
if you have men leading going forward
and other people follow suit but social
media provides a place where instead of
following the people that are strongest
and that are in charge and I'm not
saying I'm that guy but instead of
following those people and letting them
lead uh their existence is just
criticizing them and bring them down
because you get you know
digital points and money from that
so but we need men to to lead society
and everybody else to follow women
should be the ones nurturing and raising
the family and be that spiritual balance
that's necessary for for the world to
function but we're in this very confused
place where we're not sure who's who
what we should be doing uh right now
we're seeing the perfect example of Hard
Times create
um strong men and this is where Good
Times create weak men because we've had
it easy for the past 20 30 something
years in the west and we're seeing it
fall apart when weak men are in charge
so
I I believe in
growth
I think if you're not constantly growing
then you're stagnant and when you're
staying still you're unhappy and nothing
is going to be good well thank you for
coming snico tell them where they can
find you rommel.com Nico at sneako on
Twitter and we're back on Twitter back
on Twitter thank you Elon elon's doing
great things yeah he is I really like
how he's calling out the fake news media
and Elon is red pilled as he definitely
is he sees through the garbage once you
see it you can unsee it and you can
always tell who's who who kind of sees
it you know what I mean a lot of people
do see it and they choose not to to cope
yeah but yeah shout out to Elon Musk so
yeah follow me on Twitter and also the
creativitykit.com that's uh I'm host a
call once a week uh teaching people how
to make money online especially through
content creation uh if you have any
questions one-on-one you can ask me
there and I'll talk to you directly it's
50 a month and we have professors every
single day doing calls hey guys like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel make sure you go follow sunico
on Rumble
um he's literally one of the most
entertaining content creators on the
internet and
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you guys next time